good morning believe nation today's
message is always get better over to you
pitbull at the end of the day this is
called the music business so you've
gotta continue always find ways to
better your business it's kind of like
Apple you know if he stayed on on a
laptop then what would he be no but it
would've Steve Jobs and the whole team
come up with I touch iPad iPod now it's
iCloud it's always finding ways to get
better and that's the way I looked at it
through music I said well now I can just
go from rapping everybody neighborhood
to the whole world and it works and now
everybody's doing it now I gotta figure
out the next movement and I gotta figure
out my next I some for me this comes
down to having to love what you do
enjoying the process the process is the
game the journey is the game not that
final destination that you're at when I
look at a youtube video you guys may
love one of my youtube videos I look at
it and say that's great it's an amazing
video but I wanted to get better I
always wanted to get better in
everything that I do that I have passion
for I wanted to get better when Alex
who's sitting behind me working there
say hi Alex there it is when he teaches
a salsa class it could be the greatest
class that he's ever taught but he still
wants to get better he always wants it
to get better and it comes from a love
of doing the work and as soon as you set
this goal for yourself you know for me
if I if I hit half a million subscribers
on YouTube or hit a million subscribers
on YouTube it doesn't stop
I don't just quit I don't just toast
because then that's it's over that's the
end of the game I lose right if you're
only chasing that destination you're
always gonna lose in business and in
life like if you stop trying to make
your relationship better it's gonna die
if you stop trying to make your business
better it's gonna die and the only way
that I know how at least to keep that
thing alive is the passion
for the work it's not work it's
excitement what you see as my work for
me I can't wait to get up and do again
as you need to find out what that is for
you so you stop settling so that you
continue to create that next best thing
and that next best thing don't be such a
perfectionist that you don't release
something that's a downside you know
what can always be better so you never
actually put anything out there don't
let that be you put it out there but
then always make it better because it
comes from here a place where you know
that you could do better place where you
want to feel really proud of your work
we're going to invest your creative soul
and energy and fire into your work it
says always pushing and driving you
forward the minute you stop the minute
you lose that passion that's when things
start to die so the question of the day
today is I'm curious what was the last
thing that you worked on to be better at
in your business or what tests you were
running right now to be better at in
your business I'm curious leave in the
comments below I'm gonna join in the
discussion thank you guys so much for
watching have an amazing day I believe
in you and hope you continue to believe
in yourself and whatever your one word
is and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot events press
[Music]